according to legend when demons awaken
from the darkness and turn the world
into a living hell the goddess of fate
will select six heroes and these six
will be given the power to save the
world always it is only six that are
chosen and for this reason they are
known as the Braves of the six flowers
[Music]
you're the wall gotta Makua Caterham 8ij
my keep
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the semi-finals will end in ten minutes
welcome one and all the ritual
tournament semifinals will now be held
before the great king of P Anna and his
people to the west the stalwart captain
of the Royal Guard but all rain haka PNR
nation of prosperity sword to the east
representing the red bear mercenaries
photo kind of Tomaso's nation of burnt
green
this duel is unlike any you have fought
before this match is held before the
great king of Pina and the goddess of
fate who protects the world and its
peace or honor you will have a fair
fight the victor will battle princess
Nadja tania winner of the last
tournament a coward does not have the
right to face her hit all of your
strength against one another to
determine which of you is through excuse
me guys who are you my name would be
adlet myer and I am the strongest man in
the whole world
[Music]
who is he listen up everybody because we
are changing the rules today
it's like this both of you will fight me
adlet the strongest man in the world
your impudence goes too far hey get rid
of this annoying little foolish up
[Music]
but the battle begin
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
nice just an
[Music]
[Music]
water the shirt arcade
[Music]
welcome temptress
[Music]
not so fast
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
sorry
that really hurts doesn't choose well
that's what happens when they're made of
cloth hey did you see that yes I win the
semi-finals
my name is admire the strongest man in
the world
you hear that goddess of fate if you
don't choose me to be one of the six
Braves
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you don't feel remotely bad about it do
you
that was a holy tournament you ruined in
front of the king I'll never forgive you
for this
perfect I found you your adlet right and
who are you then I saw the way you
fought the guards at the tournament
grounds I was so impressed and now I'm
your biggest fan in the world
please let's shake well you're a weird
made your heart is pounding isn't it oh
are you uncomfortable talking to girls
no way the strongest man in the world
can handle anything but your face is
bright red oh I'm so glad I came I
decided that I wanted to learn more
about who you are can we talk for a
little while is that okay adlet myer age
18 nation of the white lakes my Master's
name is Autry Oh Spiker he's aa tro
Spiker at 10
i left my homeland and everything i had
to go and train with him there i lived
in the mountains for a long time
spending every hour training to defeat
the demon god
the fighting technique that he taught me
was designed for that purpose and that
purpose alone I will do whatever it
takes to succeed
that was really interesting I think I've
heard the words the strongest in the
world enough to last a lifetime
because it's an undeniable fact that I
am the strongest man in the world
remember you haven't yet beaten princess
Nadja Tonya the saint of sword
no I was hoping she would show up at
some point but I guess not
oh well how much better than she is
anyway there are lots of strong people
all over the world of course there are
but I know for a fact that there's no
fighter out there stronger than I am
what makes you think that's true it's
simple I just know that there's no one
else stronger anywhere and that's all
there is to it really you believe that
the goddess of fate knows it too now I
just need to make sure that the demon
God in the rest of the world learned
that at least you have a lot of
confidence going because it's the truth
and nothing but I guess that makes sense
can I ask you something yeah I guess so
what did they do about the tournaments
oh well they decided to go ahead and
hold the match again yesterday quato be
bought to all by a hair in the semies
and nasha tanya destroyed him in the
final round
wait nah [ __ ] Tanya sorry I should have
said the princess the old guy was really
the better one of the two they said his
shoulder was injured pretty badly when
you threw him yeah I feel kind of bad
about that
hey adlet why is it you think that
you're the strongest in the entire world
because that is the simple fact and if
I'm the strongest in the world I will
most definitely be chosen as one of the
six Braves so what you're saying is that
you know you'll be one of the Braves of
the six flowers
oh yeah
everything I've trained for has been to
defeat the demon God so you came here to
pee Anna to enter the tournament that's
right you know about the saint of the
single flower don't you of course every
single person in the country learns that
story a young maid - oh yes even a maid
a millennium ago a terrible demon
appeared on this continent it was called
the demon God and it quickly began
attacking people everywhere it went it
would kill and kill and then split its
enormous body creating new demons called
fiends that left nothing but death and
destruction behind them the armies of
the eternal Empire Rohani were all
defeated as the attacks continued the
Empire was destroyed the royal family
slain towns and villages burned off the
map
surrounded by the devastation the people
despaired and accepted their fate
then suddenly a saint appeared before
their eyes they saw her burying a
blossom so they called her the saint of
the single flower and when she appeared
there was a prolonged battle the saint
drove the demon God to the continents
west edge where she at long last
defeated him but upon her return she
said the demon God is not dead
someday it will awaken from its slumber
and turn this world into a living hell
and then she prophesied when the demon
God finally awakens six heroes will
appear bearing my power within them and
with that power they will drive the
demon God back into slumber restoring
peace to the world to bear the battles
weight those wishing to be chosen as
heroes must prove their might in the
temples of the goddess of fate built by
the saint of a single flower after
proving their strength and honor by
their victories a special mark of six
flower petals will appear on their
bodies and so because of that the people
call them the Braves of the six flowers
700 years ago they came that was the
first time in history that the six
Braves came to us the hero King fomer
the bow Saint Bona the fire Saint polka
the ice Saint Sunni myrrh the Sun Saint
Emmie and the nameless warrior Angie
then the demon King's ofer appeared at
the demon gods side at long last the
heroes succeeded in delaying zelf rare
in defeating the demon God and then 300
years ago the six Braves appeared again
rising to challenge the demon God the
blade Saint Marie the time Saint hyah ha
the Lightning Saint Melania the sword
Saint Bodil the wind se Troy and the
salt st. Manya come though some of their
number were lost in battle they were
successful in stealing the demon got in
it's been 300 years since their last
revival and in the last 10 years many
fiends have come out of hiding and
appeared on the continent a crack has
appeared in the prophecy jewel and the
crystal that tells of demons is cloudy
I believe the demon God will likely
revive within a year and that means it
won't be long at all before I'm chosen
to be one of the six Braves then I'll
put the demon God in his place do you
know the night matura witchity of the
yellow fruits country yeah
and name at least he's a young genius
Knight he's the best in the world with
the ball food Elka of the golden sands
in da Surrey the saint of ice
something happened to them they were
killed fiends probably they're killing
potential Braves before the demon gods
revival but that's not possible there's
no way the fiends should have been able
to kill them that easily you should stay
here and rest until your wounds heal
this prisons heavily guarded so don't
get any ideas
oh I'm sure it is if even a maid can
sneak in I'm sorry I really should go
before they get mad well they're sure to
be pretty mad at me anyway
but they could be even madder if you see
the princess give her a message you're
sure to be chosen as one of the six
Braves I look forward to the day we
fight together side by side okay hey
what's the matter nothing so don't worry
I'll tell her hmm whatever
you're strong but your brains are really
not there something's killing the Braves
apples
adlet myer you are sentenced to
imprisonment the length is indefinite
[Music]
ah
[Music]
am I supposed to protect myself with
this thing
[Music]
maybe it's time to escape now
what do I think
[Music]
[Music]
what's that voice speeds are on the way
look at the sky is it the Sun rising oh
look there it's coming from the
direction of coin buyer and the land of
howling demons this is not at all good
the demon God is coming
[Music]
[Music]
the crest of six flowers no it's small
so what gives probably just seeing
things
yep oh yeah hey you anyone here
listen I'm one of the Braves of the six
flowers Highness why are you here but
while I'm in a hurry
don't bother No please allow me to
introduce myself
Naja Tanya Louisiana August raha the
crown princess of Pina and the current
generation saint of blades and like you
I am chosen as one of the six Braves
lime adlet myer princess strongest man
in the world
impossible
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we need to get going I shall accompany
you our time is limited okay
[Music]
you're well-prepared aren't you
princess you haven't had your audience
with His Highness or set up the
embarkation
[Music]
[Music]
good horses he couldn't catch us not
even if they tried shall we head west
first we should head to my hideout then
we need to go to Gwen Baier the country
of iron hills the peninsula it's far end
is the land of howling demons the rule
is that those chosen as the six Braves
gather at the entrance to the land of
howling demons yeah I can hardly wait
this is gonna be great
[Music]
[Applause]
you gotta set it down haha Evita call
Danny
well does it say
Oh
[Music]
Sudama me
[Music]
don't
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
next time first journey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]